[Musique]
cher journal j'aime pas j'aime pas cette
situation j'aime pas déménager en ménage
et j'aime pas être dans les cartons
j'aime pas ça
je suis féministe mais j'aime pas
apporté les trucs lourd du coup j'ai
demandé une copine de mais des tas mais
quoi donc ce soit si l'eau est ton amour
elle est féministe 1 mais elle est même
pas capable de porter une machine à
laver tout seul du coup j'ai dû demander
un mec que j'aime pas de venir nous
aider à la portée
les familles c'est pas la question mais
alors qu'est ce qu'il est en potées
résultat il l'a fait tomber dans les
escaliers
voilà il a réussi à tout casser la
machine son bras gauche
heureusement ça va il est droitier enfin
ça l'a quand même pas empêché de râler
mais du coup en attendant qu'ils
reviennent d urgence j'étais bien obligé
d'avancer donc j'ai fait des choses j'ai
replacé des choses j'ai mesuré des
choses j'ai regardé des choses sur un
site qui vend des choses bon d'accord ok
j'ai pas fait grand chose mais même en
faisant rien j'étais plus utile que
cette équipe de bras cassés louis
mathilde est ce que tu peux décrocher
son téléphone s'il te plaît mailhiot
rose en est parce que parce que
j'attends en fait deux heures dans la
rue [ __ ] ils m'ont vraiment fait
perdre ma journée
j'en reviens pas quoi quel manque de
respect ça va se battre autour soleil
abusivement les urgences apparemment un
bras cassé ce n'est pas une priorité
confirme ce pas comme ma machine à laver
se serait pas là si je peux apporter un
truc léger sud ne pas tout casser cette
fois c'est possible
[Musique]
[ __ ] mais qu'il est content c'est pas
facile et td t td bilan fais tu t'es
bête
[ __ ] que t'es chiant de pâtes et les
loonois eu des gages
je veux plupart à temps dépêche toi je
veux bien alors je sais que je suis pas
tout le temps facile à gérer mais là
pardon c'était justifié quoi on vient
pas des bêtes c'est fou d'être bête
comme sept sont promenés pied de partout
là et puis j'en ai marre j'ai mal j'ai
mal au ventre
j'en ai marre j'en ai marre de tout le
monde là c'est bon c'est vrai on peut
couper s'il vous plaît allez on arrête
là j'en ai marre c'est bon ça pour
appeler un coin qu'on n'est pas très
agréable non plus au sort